hello and welcome everyone to the active
inference Liv stream it is active
inference Liv stream 11.1 on 12
22202 December 22nd 2020 this is going
to be a really fun discussion and
hopefully we'll see if anyone else joins
us other than that we got a nice small
group and I'm really looking forward to
talking to you all about this paper
welcome to the active inference lab
everyone the active inference lab is an
experiment in online team communication
learning and practice related to active
inference you can find us at our website
active inference dorg on Twitter at
email or YouTube channel or our public
keybase team and
username this is a recorded and an
archived live stream so please provide
us with feedback so that we can improve
on our work all backgrounds and
perspectives are welcome here and as far
as video etiquette for live streams mute
if there's noise in your background
raise your hands so that we can hear
from everybody who wants to speak and
we'll use respectful speech Behavior Etc
so just a couple points of process today
on December 22nd we are in
11.1 and next week will be the last act
imp stream for 2020 on December 29th
2020 and that will be at 7:30 to 900
a.m. PST on the same paper that we're
talking about today and everyone is
welcome to join then then we are very
happy to announce the active inference
stream schedule for 2021 which can be
found at this rb. gy link going to this
link you'll be able to find out which
papers we'll be discussing which week
and how to participate if you are so
interested and also all these sessions
come and join for however much you can
so if you have to join late or leave
early it's all good we just want to have
participation and your
perspective this is what the calendar
looks like so looking ahead to some of
the first paper we're going to discuss
the first weeks of January we're going
to be discussing um in 13 a paper by
Adam saffron and Colin D young uh in the
second weeks of January we're going to
be talking about Mel Andrew's paper the
math is not the territory so everybody
should be finding exciting papers and
letting us know when we can read them
for AC
infam also just one last note if you go
to active inference dorg you'll see a
call for collaboration for the active
inference lab 2021 so check that out if
you'd like to get involved in any way
okay thanks for all that here we are in
active inference stream 11.1 and today
first we are going to have introductions
and warm-up questions and then we're
going to turn to the sections of
11.1 the paper we're discussing is
sophisticated affective inference
simulating anticipatory affective
dynamics of imagining future events by
Casper hesp at all in 2020 from the iy
proceedings we're going to talk about
the aims and claims the abstract and the
road map and then we'll go through the
figures and maybe even some of the
citations that are referenced in the
paper next week we're going to be
discussing the same paper so save and
submit your questions and get in touch
if you'd like to participate okay here
we are in the intros and warm-ups so
let's introduce ourselves we can each
give a short introduction or check-in
and then pass to somebody who hasn't
spoken so I'm Daniel I'm in California
and I'll pass it to
Sasha hi I'm Sasha I'm also in
California and I will pass it to
Blue hi I'm blue I'm based out of New
Mexico I'm an independent research
consultant looking at um bioinformatics
a lot and a lot of agent based modeling
mostly and I'll pass it to
Stephen hello I'm Stephen I'm based in
Canada in Toronto and I'm interested in
um the ways active inference can help
inform the ways groups and communities
understand their place in the world and
I will pass it over to Ian let's go to
Alex
actually oh sorry
I yeah hello my name is Alex I in Moscow
Russia I'm a researcher in systems
management school and I'm trying to find
interconnections and possible ways to
connect
with uh systems engineering and system
thinking
Frameworks awesome and have uh we a new
fellow jiter it could be Ryan so anytime
that Ryan or anyone joins we'll just hop
in and go from
there um okay I just want to check these
messages all right thanks okay let's go
to the warm-up questions so for the
warm-up questions we can each just raise
our hand give some thoughts and we'll
have plenty of time in today's
relatively small discussion to get
through everyone's thoughts on the paper
and on the associate areas so first just
an introductory question is what gets
you excited to read and discuss this
paper so thanks everyone for showing up
and for those who are listening live and
in replay and I'll tie that to the
second question as well how can we learn
and communicate the technical aspects of
active inference in an accessible
fashion so it's kind of like intention
setting as we head into this relatively
technical paper and indeed relatively
technical area of active inference that
draws on mathematics and computer
science and a few other areas so again
anyone can raise their hand but I'll
give a first answer just think about
what's something that gets you excited
uh in terms of the content and then from
a process-based perspective what is a
way that we can learn and communicate
accessibly so what um let's go with
Stephen first
Well I this is interesting because I
think this discussion came up on one of
our conversations on our chats I think
finding different ways in um will give
you different ways to communicate to the
different people that you're talking to
so I think active
inference needs to be connected to some
process that people are familiar with in
terms of how they make meaning in the
world um otherwise it's a big big jump
to build it all from first
principles yes so definitely it's
exciting to hear about things that we've
heard about in A New Perspective so I
agree when we see keywords in an active
inference paper and we know that it's
going to be like familiar territory but
approach from a different angle that's
exciting uh any other thoughts
there
Alex yeah thanks uh for me it was
interesting how
uh provide an example and the the case
for defining agent and generative model
for this agent and so as a result to
have simulation as possible ways way
to in a more practical way when we
usually discuss on papers here is like
exact case for
simulation thanks okay blue
so I think a lot of things were exciting
to me but like computational Psychiatry
that's a field like what is that about
um but I mean it it really just kind of
hones in on like maybe are we like a sum
of input output like is our effective
State like just direct result of our
input and if so like I don't know that
it feels a little bit like Brave New
worldish like are we going to move
toward you know control theory and
optimization of
affective State it's kind of um just
like crazy and a little bit scary to me
yep from implicitly to explicitly
steering others behavior and veillance
and affect
Sasha um yeah I just remember this
reading this paper when it uh came out
earlier this year and thinking like what
does affect have to do with uh agents
and and why is that important to model
or to include
um mathematically and so that's been
something I'm still thinking about um
and um yeah very interested in the
aspects of uh you know computational
Psychiatry and yeah I guess just on a
deeper level reminds us that um affect
and mood are really important aspects of
The Human Experience and not something
to be um
ignored uh in favor of like bigger
decision aspects um that it really does
matter yeah one thought on that is that
in active inference we're always talking
about how everything is prediction and
then we're always talking about how
prediction isn't just a point estimate
of what will happen it's actually a
state estimate and an uncertainty about
that estimate so you know I predict the
Giants are going to win the World Series
and I'm this certain about it or I'm not
certain about it so it's always the
state estimation and the uncertainty and
so that uncertainty is the risk or the
ambiguity depending on the context and
then the state itself good versus bad is
the veilance and so it's sort of like
the affect which is multi-dimensional
contains something about how good or bad
it is and then orthogonally or
independently whether it's good or bad
is whether you're confident or not and
so you could be very confident about
being happy or very confident about
being sad Ryan we see you joining can
you hear
us not sure while Ryan is is um figuring
out his setup but thanks Sasha for
bringing up the computational Psychiatry
angle and I hope that Ryan will be able
to fill us in soon
Stephen yeah I think this is a really
important point because when we think
about how things happen over time in
this process how that gets integrated
how we make sense not just in some sort
of snapshot about a situation I.E we
think this is a problem situation and
then suddenly there's this emotional
churn that's somehow a byproduct of that
but actually it's not a snapshot this
ongoing process which seems incredibly
impossibly complex is made all of it's
made sense of because of affect and
emotion it's not some
Freudian sort of repression that's
sitting there in the background as a as
a as a mistake but it's actually like
the big game in town which is pretty
revolutionary really
interesting and also uh yet another
transformation or sort of Paradigm Shift
associated with thinking from a free
energy perspective is rather than
prioritizing the veilance the Plus
versus minus and then having risk or
ambiguity as a secondary layer we can
actually think about the ambiguity
reduction as the primary drive and then
the plus and minus as falling out of the
quest to reduce uncertainty rather than
uncertainty being an auxilary factor in
the to improve outcomes so it just shows
how there's these two related dimensions
of prediction which is the state and the
uncertainty and then we can think about
how prioritizing one or the other is
going to lead to different outcomes Ryan
we can see you raise your hand can you
talk okay how about you can raise your
hand and lower it in Morse code and
we'll communicate with you that
way but Ryan thanks for trying and if
it's not working with your current
browser setup for whatever reason today
then we'll make sure to work it out with
you in the interm and for next week and
for following discussions will have you
on unabated all right and here's our
last warm-up question which is something
that you are wondering about or would
like to have resolved by the end of
today's
discussion
blue so I don't really expect this to be
resolved but I wonder instead of um
modeling you know to predict like
positive or negative veilance like if
there is a way to model um like equinity
in this in this sense like so neutral
veilance like is that um I mean what
what would drive that force and so I'm
just kind of wondering as as we dive
deeper into the model if that's going to
become clear or not can you um explain
what you mean by that and what types of
models might exist to think about
that um so just like how you know the
results here were geared obviously
toward um you know pushing a affect
towards either a positive state or
driving away from a negative State I
mean that's I assume the idea so what
about driving toward a neutral State
like is is this something that's been
considered right like so you know
overthinking tends to lead like
overthinking like supposing about the
future leads to like you know these
supposed negative thoughts that and so
then it's anxiety producing because
you're worried about these negative
thoughts like so that's overthinking or
thinking like worst case scenario
perhaps right so people do like a lot of
thought redirection in this cognitive
behavioral therapy like people do
thought redirection so that maybe you're
thinking in not such a Negative state
but but in a more positive way like well
it could also be great right like so
there's that but what about like the
non-thinking so if you non-thinking
a veilance neutral like veilance equals
zero to just have this kind of equinity
Baseline that's like something maybe
medit meditation achieves right so like
can you can you work towards like non-
think maybe non-thinking is that that
veillance neutral right like so I don't
know how how um how can that factor into
computational Psychiatry and it has that
been thought of before I don't know cool
great question and so it's kind of like
if we were going to be doing modeling of
a car
there's probably a lot of different ways
that you could set up car crashes or
cars that drive off the rails and we
just want to know about what does it
look like to have a computational
Psychiatry model that isn't just
capturing a negative spiral as
overthinking progressively sort of
accelerates but rather something that
returns to a neutral attractor state or
something that's related to mindfulness
or attention to detail or abstraction
but not hyper abstraction rumination but
not hyper rumination so could the
strange attractor be a neutral or even a
healthy one not a delusionally positive
or negative
Stephen I suppose you could say that
like there's thousands and thousands of
Dimensions which are kind of sitting
there as neutral and you really notice
it when you you're not there and you got
to reestablish it so that's what they
talk about in sense making is when
you're immersed in something you don't
do sense making but once you Sonic jolts
you out of it certain consciously you
might be doing unconscious sense making
but at more of conscious level is when
you're surprised basically when things
aren't going the way that your habitual
understanding of them are and then
suddenly your cognition is got to kick
in and say okay how do I work out what
is the sense of what I should be doing
at the moment and that's when everything
becomes transparent so it's it's quite
interesting to actually then see this
now that the again taking that that
thinking and and that sort of abstract
and bring it right into the body and the
and and the emotions as the kind of like
the way of really knowing I mean in some
ways is your mind checking in with your
body or is your body checking in with
your
mind cool very interesting about the
mind and the body and always an
important take um any other thoughts
here or can we continue
Sasha um yeah another aspect of this
paper I really liked is discussing the
um like future clinical applications of
understanding the
mechanism of how certain existing
therapies work because there's a lot of
different kinds of therapies out there
um and namely I'm thinking of like art
therapy
and but of course all other forms
included um to understand to start to
understand why they work and by what
mechanism um they might be tapping into
uh this kind of affective and predictive
coding um so I I think that's really
exciting and I also wonder who is fit to
address those kinds of questions is it
medical professionals um is it uh
psychologist um who is best suited for
that role because um it's a very you
know uh challenging subject to talk
about without um giving people perhaps
uh incorrect medical advice or false
hope and so that that's just something
that um I'm curious about but I don't
want to step on any
toes cool let's keep that in mind and as
Ryan joins and rejoins but no need to
send the jitsy messages because we can
hear it very loudly so let's just hope
that Ryan can figure it out otherwise
we'll take care of it for next week cool
here we are in the paper for today which
is sophisticated affective inference
simul ulating anticipatory affective
dynamics of imagining future events and
this was from October 2020 in the first
International workshop on active
inference or iy and I believe that more
recently like in the last couple of days
this has been codified into a book so um
we're using the research gate
version the aims and the claims of the
paper were a bit rehearsed in 11.0 so go
and check that one out if you want a
deeper dive into what the aims and the
claims were
but the big point of this paper was to
take two bodies of previous work which
was the sophisticated inference which is
sophisticated meaning deep through time
and then affective inference affect
being related to emotion and veilance
and fusing these two threads into
sophisticated affective inference so
deep through time and also involving
aect and the big question from a
non-active inference jargon perspective
is how to model affective and
anticipatory agents of course we're
going to be thinking about that within
the active inference framework and then
we're going to be asking what features
do these simulated agents display and
then how does this carry out or connect
to areas that are like Psychiatry or
cybernetics control theory all these fun
things that we've been talking about in
previous actm streams how are we going
to connect what we're learning about
today something that's a recent
development in only the last couple
months this is the current developments
so let's have fun let's um treat it as
just an initial inroad and a connection
between these two different
areas here's the abstract and again it
was read through in 11.0 and we're going
to just go more discussion oriented in
the panels that we have but
fundamentally in the abstract they
describe what I just said that they
combine those two different types of
active inference models sophisticated
and deep parametric models and then they
use a augmented marov decision process
please know jitsy chat if possible thank
you Ryan we'll see you soon um and uh
then they give a minimal simulation at
the end of a ruminating agent and that
is where blue was talking about the
negative agent that sort of spirals off
into negative
affect okay um the road map of the paper
there's not that many stops not that
many gas stations along the way it's
also a short paper and I have it in this
other tab if we want to um go through it
as it is as a paper because it's so
clear and concise but what they do is
introduce the ideas then show a couple
figures that just summarize the model
and show a table with what the uh
formalisms were at this point does
anyone have any thoughts or where do we
want to go like what was something that
somebody thought structurally or from a
topical perspective that they wanted to
bring up or it's okay if
not all right let's uh look at the
figures and then use the figures as our
scaffold for kind of understanding what
they are up to in this paper and then
understand why they did some of the
things that they did and then what some
of the next steps could be so here we
are in figure one and figure one does
anyone want to point something out that
they see first
so feel free to just raise your hand any
time um in figure one I've put red boxes
around two pieces these are the two
pillars that things are being built upon
here is the aect of inference part which
we'll get to in a second and then in the
the middle is the task specific
sophisticated inference so that's deep
inference here and then as with a few
other figures we've seen time is moving
from left to right now in this model
there's several boxes that are shaded
and that's because there's this
recursive embedding of the models so we
start with one single time Point that's
this up here on the top level of the
model this is like the outer layer of
the model it's kind of like the hour
hand of the model you can think of and
what's happening at each time point of
the model itself is that the agent is
doing a forecast through time so it's
kind of like in the year 2000 you're
doing a forecast for the next 100 years
and then it's a recursive string because
at 2000 you do a 100-year prediction and
then 2001 you do 100-year prediction so
it's like at each time Point each big
hour tick of the big model we're going
to be doing this recursive uh rolling
out of predictions through time so
that's the biggest structure of the
model is top level is the actual time
that's the real what's happening in the
world we can think but then the agent is
involved in this recursive of
anticipatory simulation and that's the
Deep or the sophisticated inference now
there's a few other elements to
highlight and again anyone can raise
your hand at any time the first thing is
that within this prediction through time
we've seen a couple elements here we've
seen s the states a how the hidden State
estimates are mapped to observations
we've also seen b which is how the
states change through time or are
predicted to change through time again
this is like happening with within an
instance of the agent we've also seen U
which is how actions how policy maps on
to the way that states change remember
that policy enters the B Matrix so
states are being inferred and then we're
inferring the B Matrix which is
basically how our policies affect how
States influence uh how States change
Through Time Another notable feature
here and slightly outside of the blue
box but in the gray box is this gamma or
a Precision parameter so as we do this
roll out at a given instant and think
ahead Through Time how things are going
to be we're not just estimating the
state roll out through time we're also
estimating our actions through time and
how that influences States and how they
change and a layer above that is this
gamma which is how sure am I about that
that's this layer of precision in the
estimate and that's coming through this
G which is um related to the estimate
free energy so again for each moment of
the roll out the agent is estimating a
bunch of things inside this model and
then Steph I'll get to you after I
finish this last little bit and then in
the moment in the actual timeline of the
agent it is having aect and so these are
the ways that these two models are
combined and we can look at some more um
unpacking in other slides but I just
wanted to start with the actual figure
used in the paper itself before going to
another citation and the sophisticated
inference is capturing this deep roll
out at an instance with a Precision
estimator and the affective inference is
capturing this affective state that
carries forward in time and so combining
affective and sophisticated inference is
quite literally structurally combining
the patterns of affective inference from
this hesp at all citation with the
topological model structures of
sophisticated inference we'll stay on
here and continue thinking about it
Stephen so would I be right in saying
that the the
effective inference over time is is kind
of looking at the shape of how actions
look like they're going to turn out over
time and and sort of put in a feeling to
that in a simplistic term it's like
there's it's not so you've got all these
fairly discret moments being looked at
or assessed over time and the sort of
the shape of that
is what the feeling is about that makes
sense it's like is it going is is is it
like am I predicting this to be a roller
coaster ride of uncertainty over the
next few minutes or am I expecting it to
be smooth you know because that would be
the kind of the shape of the
observations and the expectations as I
stretch it out over time and that itself
becomes something which is abs you know
has a generative
model um tracking it would that be a one
way of saying it great and thanks for
phrasing it in the wording as it appears
to you so let's start with that shape of
the prediction that shape is actually
the shape of a probability distribution
it's the shape of the probability
distribution that is a generative model
and the shape of that it's kind of like
a cloud of points or the bubble that
encloses the cloud of points it's a a
shape that is existing let's just think
initially in two Dimensions so like a
piece of paper and on the y- AIS is
going to be how rewarding is it lots of
reward or negative reward and then the
x-axis is precision from low Precision
to high precision and so you could
imagine that the shape could be all the
way clustered up on the top right corner
so that would be high expected reward
but High Precision that's the best state
the lowest state would be like the
bottom left where it's like low expected
reward and low Precision so again the
reward prioritizing mindset says the
agents State Should correspond to their
state estimate the active inference
perspective says no no no the agent's
affect is going to be related to their
uncertainty estimate more so because if
you have a small positive State estimate
but you're very precise I'm going to
give you $5 plus or minus 1 cent you'd
say great and if you say I'm going to
give you $5 plus orus $25 you say wait a
minute you're going to maybe take $20
from me even if it's a very small chance
that isn't as good as getting five plus
or minus one and so this is where the
state estimate and the Precision
estimator are orthagonal and so that's
what delineates the shape of the
distribution that is the generative
model of the future now in a traditional
computational psychology model again
agent affect would be tracked by the
state estimate if it's a above zero
expected then you're good if it's below
zero it's bad whereas in the active
inference framework good affect is going
to be associated with precise estimates
and anxiety negative affect is going to
be associated with high uncertainty and
so as this agent runs simulations going
forward and rolling them out we can look
at what that looks like even if the
expected reward is positive if the
ambiguity is high the uncertainty is
high it can be anxiety
producing so that is what we're really
tracking is there's the structure of
this model which is like the topology or
the connectedness of how different
variables influence each other in the
model but then the outcome of all of
this is the shape of the distribution of
the prediction of the agent and that's
respectively just like all predictions
are about State as well as uncertainty
so estimate about the world States the
hidden states in the world and then a
metacognitive estimate of our decision
and so it's like this is one click
through time and then the agent acts but
it's simulating its future actions at
this moment and then the actual model
clicks over and then it's in the next
time step for the agent and it starts
simulating from that moment going
forward and so that's one of the
features that is uh something that's a
Hallmark of this model is it's like the
game that's being played has a net
positive return and let's just just
assume that we had a degree of agency we
could probably choose small winning
outcomes within this game that we're
about to show however by spiraling and
by ruminating Deep through time the
agent starts thinking about potential
roads that are highly uh rewarding as
well as a small fraction of paths that
are very negative and then the
uncertainty in that distribution the
spread on the x-axis or the higher
uncertainty on the x-axis is actually
leading to it being anxiety producing
even if the state estimate is positive
Stephen yeah I think this is this
supports some of the challenges we also
find with you know if you you see the
the numbers for the stock market you can
get this sense of full sense of
certainty that we all know what's going
on and it gives this for some people
that can make them quite relaxed and
confident and here I go you know um
bullish as we might say and this this
would sort of support that sense of like
um if you're given this high level of
supposedly precision and um supposed um
accuracy and reliability you could get a
full sense of of of that and and that
could be where you know at the same time
people challenge that and look at like
we need to blow that apart because you
know if you if if the confidence in that
suddenly disappears and you see it as
not being as precise as you thought the
anxiety Rises greatly and you know
otherwi ways of thinking might need to
be thought you know come into play cool
good connection there with decision
making in markets which are very related
to not just estimates of value but
estimates of volatility and uncertainty
estimates about value and about
volatility and so then you have people
trading vix you know trading the
volatility index or leveraging that and
so these are like higher level ambiguity
about ambiguity or risk about risk
and then all of that is associated with
veilance is it a good trade or a bad
trade and so that's like coming back to
Sasha's question about veilance and
affect it's sort of like well there's so
many layers and ways that you could
leverage trading but then in the end
it's like right but am I going to do
action a or not is it going to be a or b
is it a good trade or not and that
implicitly entails preferences like I
want to see my number of Bitcoin go up
not down but if you didn't have that
preference which is part of the C Matrix
which is not shown here it's part of the
G if you didn't have a preference then
you wouldn't know which policy to
partake in like if you don't know where
you're going every step is a losing step
but then with a preference Vector C you
can actually ask is this trade a good
one or a bad one and that is not just is
the expected value above zero again
that's reward landia that's reward first
uncertainty as a satellite we're taking
uncertainty first and we still want to
partake in in preferences uh in
preference guided policy selection so
instead of doing preferences to reward
maximization and then we'll deal with
the uncertainty later it's like let's go
from preference to policy selection with
ambiguity as the heart of what we're
doing and reward will fall out as a
function of reducing uncertainty about
optimal action in the world given our
preferences and affordances so this is
sort of the simple uh rearranging of
ideas and reconfiguring that leads to
some of these Innovative insights in
active inference
Stephen just adding something into that
is also shows it can work the other way
I I know someone who does trading and he
has to sort of monitor his heart rate
they do a whole thing where he does like
some relaxing and measures the heart
rate and that before doing the work so
that the state of the body
doesn't mask what's actually going on
you know so this also shows that you
know if your physical state and your you
know emotional state is is is out of
whack in any way your your ability to to
do this deep inference might be skewed
or even you know uh lost because the the
top level in the diagram is not
necessarily tapping into the real data
it's just tapping into the the the the
values about context arous or
Etc that is just in the whole system for
the person correct and there's a lot of
Behavioral research not done in the
active inference framework that shows
like when people are in a pessimistic
framework they might be more willing to
satisfice with like a smaller gain in
the short term whereas when somebody's
feeling like abundant or optimistic or
confident about their success they might
be able to delay gratification and
partake in larger gains in the future
and so if you have somebody who's
carrying over from the other tab quite
literally negative affect or adversarial
affect about the world and they flip
over their trading account they're going
to be making different kinds of
decisions based upon their affect of
state that's going to carry into their
estimates of precision which is related
to anxiety higher Precision lower
anxiety those two are negatively
correlated and then again in this
caption the um imagined action model
Precision actions States and outcomes
everything inside of the gray and the
blue box is inside the mind of an agent
at a moment and so this is the roll out
inside of the mind of an agent at a
moment let's look at figure two and talk
about this game that they actually
simulate out so this is Four State game
um it's uh there's a lot of games that
you could simulate but this is just one
game and each of the edges reflect
transitions that are possible so you
start on like square one and then you
can either move to square two or Square
three with some probability and you
start out with gain of zero it's a
neutral State you can go to a safe small
gain so if you're just wanting to play
it safe you could hang out and go
between one and two however also you can
go to this High Gain three now three
you're getting twice as much money
however there's a one and three chance
that you're going to or depending on how
these edges are parameterized I should
say there's a chance that you can move
into this absorbing State that's painful
and so the two adjectives there are
painful so it has a negative reward of
negative -2 and it's absorbing because
you see that it can also uh swallow your
trajectory like once you end up in four
it's sort of like a negative State and
so there are absorbing states in the
world like death let's say once you hit
this state you're staying in that state
and so the agent is starting here and so
it's like which Square should I walk on
to get um you know the most money or
something like that and so if it just
walks around it's going to end up here
really quickly and get into this painful
absorbing State and so it's thinking
okay there's some paths I can imagine
where I just walk back and forth between
one and two there's some other paths
where I walk around on one two three I'm
just getting money or neutral on every
step and so what it's doing here is time
one it's saying well on my next move I
could go to one two or three and I could
go to four but actually this Edge isn't
there so it's it's like not likely so
the first step it's like it's literally
all good your expectation is either one
or two so your kind of estimate is a
mean of one and a half with a small
variance okay but now here if you stay
on one and then continue on one now
you're getting this path at time point
three would give you zero here you'd
have $1 total 0 01 here you'd have $3
total here you'd have plus one Z so 1 2
4 here you'd have 2 + 2 is four so
you're getting all these estimates now
you have some fours but you also have
some two negative twos and some uh
negative fours so as you're rolling out
this simulation at each time Point
actually the expectation is getting
higher because if you think about it you
can get -2 or plus two that cancels out
and then plus one so each game you play
each step the expectation is going to
strictly grow however the variance is
also going to strictly grow and so this
is related to a few other probability
games where it's like will you play this
game will we Gamble and then it's like
double or nothing uh uh following double
or nothing it's like the St Peters St
Petersburg uh Gamble it has another name
as well and the reason why people don't
pay infinite money to pay these uh to
play these games with an infinite
expected value is because the variance
is so high and so what's happening is as
the agent is rolling out in its mind
these possible trajectories and this
could be like chest trajectories or it
could be like action selection policies
or trades as it's rolling these out the
variance is increasing and so that's
making it anxious um that's sort of the
heart of what's happening and then as we
Trace out the time steps of the model
this is again just one trace of the
simulation they're not exploring every
parameter but this is very illustrative
what happens is that in the first couple
of hundred uh time points of the model
the veilance is good the agent is
feeling good it's feeling good about
ending up in large reward States and it
has a fairly precise model on action and
a small fraction of an of the imagined
events are negative 04 but then what
starts happening is because that
negative state is absorbing you get more
and more trajectories lining up on this
right side where it's like four as an
absorbing State and so that is making
that uh making the uncertainty strictly
rise so around 500 we have this phase
transition where the Precision on the
agent's estimate drops rapidly it's like
yeah I'm not sure what's going to happen
after 500 time points because there's
some paths that are just super bad and
there's some that are super good so when
it was one time point I was like pretty
sure I was going to get $1 or $2 and I
felt great but now that you're asking me
to predict 500 time points out I don't
know if I'm going to have $100,000 or be
$100,000 in debt and that's actually
getting me anxious that I don't know the
Precision and so again if someone said
hey don't worry about the future because
the expected value is going to be
positive $1,000 that's not $1,000 in my
pocket that's a precise ,000 if somebody
says the expected value is $1,000 but it
has a huge variance it's going to be
anxiety producing and so even though the
threat perception is inching up from
0.04 to .1 so it still is not more than
a 10% uh barely chance of these highly
threatening events happening it turns
out that um the uncertainty is what
drives the veilance not the percentage
of negative events and then also
interestingly and this could be over
reading into one trace of the model but
the phase transition and the Precision
and uh veilance happen at exactly the
same time around 500 right before 500
interestingly the threat perception is
going down over overall leading up to
500 and then it starts kicking up again
that's sort of like okay I drank all the
coffee I'm feeling great it's like oh no
I'm starting to get a little tired that
coffee is's not going to work that
quantitative easing is not going to work
and so even though the threat perception
actually isn't as high as it has been
the Precision being so low leads to the
veilance being negative because the
veilance is being derived again from the
anxiety from the uncertainty not from
the expected value this is like a point
we can always return to because it's a
great example of the complimentarity of
traditional reward Centric
understandings of reward learning and
this more Precision guided understanding
of action selection in the niche okay
any thoughts on those
figures that's sort of the contribution
of the paper in many ways is just to
make this combination model that
features the aect of inference of the
agent in their timeline and then at each
moment this imagined roll out and um
yeah it's a discreet time model and uh
yeah any thoughts or questions or
there's more stuff we can continue to
look
through cool so just to put it up there
and anyone can raise their hand table
one has some of the mathematical details
so hopefully with Ryan and any other
authors next week we'll be able to talk
about these details and uh here is that
that gamma which is one over the
Precision so sometimes you'll hear about
it as Precision maximizing other times
you'll hear about it as
uncertainty uh minimizing and those two
the Min and the max are related by this
one over feature just one point so it's
kind of like um on network uh networks
there's one type of problem called the
max flow like you want to have flow
through a network internet or water or
resources and so you might want to know
what the uh cut is that's going to be
most damaging or the least damaging to
the network so sometimes the most and
the least are related by this one over
feature um okay any thoughts because
there's a lot of formalisms we can
continue to walk through and we have a
good amount of time but like maybe just
pausing here what would be something you
would say to somebody who had never
heard of active inference and just what
is something that it captures that other
models haven't captured or something
that you'd be excited to see it head in
the direction towards Stephen thanks
well I think the counterintuitive nature
um and the ability for things to be
unexpectedly stable and unexpectedly
transitioned um is something
that I don't know of a way that
traditional models of the world would
show you you know because you know you
could be like oh people would normally
either just take one of those moments
and then that gets extrapolated for
everything but actually you need to
follow it over time because it matters a
lot it does and it needs to be um kind
of through time in two ways the actual
agent needs to be progressing through
time but at each time point the agent
needs to be simulating time points of
the past present and future
and so that's this like double timeline
that's happening with the models
topology here is you could have another
pink box right next to this one and that
would be like the next time point of the
agent but it's like right now it's 10:00
a.m. and I'm looking ahead to 10 11 12
and then it's 11 and then I'm thinking
ahead again but I'm also looking back
and all of that is being spun out of a
generative model of a trajectory
Stephen yeah that's and I thought it was
interesting I haven't seen a positive
veilance and a negative veilance I
haven't seen sort of
two Dynamics mapped alongside each other
simultaneously normally there's just the
one so I thought that's something that's
kind of uh the good and bad as two you
know it's not just about good it's about
the blending of good and bad I thought
that's so I mean theoretically you could
have loads of V variants of that you
know you could have good the bad the
ugly yep yep veilance just like uh an
electron or proton you know veence of
plus or minus that's plus to minus
positive to negative veence but affect
is a multi-dimensional landscape and so
that is something that could be explored
in a higher dimensional way but again
let's think about that trading example
there's so many ways oh it's an elegant
trade it's an ugly trade it was a clumsy
one it was a uh uh one with very much
foresight or it was a retributive trait
all these adjectives but then what does
it boil down to given my preferences and
my affordances was it a good trade and
that if your preferences are hey I have
too much money I'm trying to sponsor a
couple people who have less crypto than
me then a quote good trade given that
preference Vector might not look like a
preference uh or a policy selected by
somebody with a different preference so
that is where agent specific preferences
come into play is you're never going to
get away from that the agent is not
doing this neutral calculation followed
by a secondary step of policy selection
the preferences for policy and for
outcomes are entrenched within the
kernel of this model at every single
time step
Stephen and and that gives a plausible
basian route to your gut feeling I mean
some of those emotions like you're
saying the An Elegant trade might be
kind of a cognitive process and uh and
some other type of part of it might be
kicking your deep you know there are
certain times when you're thinking about
stuff and then suddenly you get a
sinking feeling in your stomach you know
and it's like well that that um that who
knows where that's coming from but this
gives a you only get one
overall sort of gut feeling you only get
one overall sort of um route to actively
infer how to take action in the world
and all these different things they only
become available to you when you maybe
reflect on it later and you have to
describe what why you had that gut
feeling like you just mentioned there
could be hundreds of different things
all being basly integrated exactly and
that's this go noo hey I'm just not
feeling good about this this whole
vacation or I'm just feeling really
great I don't know what's behind the
door number four but I'm feeling great
about it that veilance aspect of
prediction for the future is like the
highest level control summary statistic
it's like are we going to accept this
person into the college or not there's
so many other dimensions but it gets
distilled into the choke point through
the marov blanket of action it gets
distilled into go or no go on that
specific person or that specific policy
or that specific outcome and so that's
actually the justification for the use
of veilance as a simple positive to
negative even though there's so many
other dimensions to affect overall it
does get distilled into this gut feeling
which you can go into and and uh you can
cognize you can add adjectives on top
but it's sort of interesting it's like
is the gut feeling just positive versus
negative and when you introspect do you
get higher and higher levels of
abstracted polysyllabic emotions or do
you get deeper and deeper into your body
and into increasingly summary statistics
like go no go um freeze fight these are
things like go and noo let's look
through a couple oh Sasha go
ahead that's kind of what I was thinking
is with this model of veilance would uh
a human participant let's say um be able
to self-report in the similar way about
um their veillance during an experience
or is this kind of like the you know
hidden by the marov blanket and um we
can have these models to help explain
what was happening at the time but those
States might be unaccessible to uh
people actually experiencing this you
know decision-making
process and um yeah it just reminds me
of I guess how people spend money and
thinking about economic um economic
decisions that uh people make that are
you know either logical or not logical
and that it really um has little to do
with
the money that we have and then the
mindset that we have about the money and
like how we ought to be spending it and
um you know who we want to be supporting
or not with our uh investment decision
and yeah it just really uh I don't know
it it's at such a higher level than um
just thinking about someone's salary
it's how they interact with the economic
system and um what role they might play
in it and just especially in the
holidays like all I can think is we're
so deeply influenced
by um times and like season and
tradition with how we choose to uh how
and where we choose to spend money right
you send money you literally give money
away to people on their birthday on
their biorhythm or you know in the
holiday season as then also what you
just said Sasha reminded me of like
course graining estimates and why it's
so important if your economic estimate
that you're making is will we have
enough or not you might be very
confident that you'll have enough say I
don't know the details but I'm confident
that we'll have enough or even I'm
confident we're not going to have enough
and we're going to have to do XYZ policy
okay we can work with that but if you're
trying to do a estimate down to the
scent you might have a very noisy
estimate and then apparently people can
get quite anxious about relatively small
amounts of money that are way up there
in the big salary range is it going to
be this number or a slightly higher or a
slightly smaller number so there's this
jockeying and uncertainty up there at
the high level because they're doing a
nine fig Precision estimate with a large
variance whereas there's something to be
said for coar graining and simplifying
and functionalizing it and actually not
just reducing the cognitive load but
increasing the Precision of our estimate
even if the state estimate is inferior
so there's so much there to continue
exploring let's just walk through some
more of these formalisms because most of
this paper um we can just scroll through
it just to you know show you but it's 10
pages long including references and
basically they
introduce give that figure one that we
just looked at give figure two that we
just looked at give the table we looked
at show the results for figure three and
there's the whole paper so it's short
very very short so let's go into these
two citations underlying the Paper
Central and then just find out what they
might show
us and we're going to be talking about
deeply felt affect in April I believe so
again sophisticated affective inference
is drawing the affect from this left
side and the temporal depth from the
right
side three areas we could imagine this
area of research heading towards would
be more advanced simulations so agents
that are simulating in continuous time
or with higher dimensional action
policies just like we've seen from actm
8 with scaling active inference or
towards the computational Psychiatry
angle something that Ryan Smith and
others have written review papers about
and a lot of empirical work as well so
we'll hear more about that next time and
then there's this angle of the models
for robotics which is like what if the
Drone had a top level summary statistic
that's just like is this Mission going
well or not and if not then that might
engage some um policies like head back
home or pause or land or get to safety
but that's a top level summary statistic
that even robots might be able to
utilize and I know that some people are
doing that kind of
stuff so in sophisticated inference and
this is to bridge the gap between the
formalisms and the actual sentences that
are driving us we're going to kind of
write it in a little bit of a hybrid
script like a Rebus so the big question
that agents are trying to answer in the
world and in F sophisticated inference
is how can we have the best policy over
a given time Horizon so not what's the
best chess move now it's what's the best
chess move over the time Horizon that
I'm
considering and tied up in that question
about evaluating the best policy over a
given time Horizon is the question of
what are the consequences of policies
through time and how do estimate that
what is our
estimate and what that is related to how
we how we Benchmark how we compare
policies and their consequences is
specifically related to how we
understand observations being mapped to
Hidden States and our policy which is
how our actions are influencing the way
that hidden States change between each
other that's that b
Matrix and the generalized free energy
which is this par and friston citation
so another citation link away from the
iwi paper is that the generalized free
energy basically consists of one model
that conditions on policies and then
asks about how State transitions occur
so conditioning on me exercising every
day what kind of state transitions can I
expect to see in the world and then the
second part of the free energy is
conditioning on States What policies
should be selected so this is the
two-stroke engine conditioned on what I
know about the world world state and
causal model of the world generative
model of the world what is my policy
selection that's the control theory
that's the cybernetic side that's the
action side um action looking side and
then this first part is again
conditioning on my policies in the world
what are the state Transitions and how
did those change and there's more Nuance
because of course we're just describing
it in natural language but this is sort
of the broad outline one half of free
energy conditions on policy the other
part um selects policy and basically
vice versa with State
Transitions and so here's related to
this q and P which we saw in Tale of Two
densities we talked about it again in
integrating internalism and externalism
Q conditions on policy that's a vertical
line P your estimating o and S through T
through time as conditioned on P and
then uh p is conditioned on States so
again we're conditioning on two
different parts and uh that's also uh
how we end up using this two-stroke
engine to do inference in complex
settings we also talked about amortized
inference but don't want to go into that
here blue this is the slide that uh
always makes me think about you with uh
where's the information gain and could
the pure information gaining agent get
reward or does the pure reward Seeker
gain information and like where is this
play interplay between the intrinsic
values or the salience and then the
intrinsic value in the novelty so the
way that these two and all all these
different features and the different
representations I mean there's so much
to say about and think here but Stephen
and then anyone
else yeah could you just go back to that
the one where you put those two terms
between action the generative model and
the that one yeah see that's kind of
interesting that generative model says
State transition
policies and policies final States so
policiy final States is probably a bit
more
action and like least energy rout and
the other one maybe is a bit more
generative model is a bit more
processing sensory data it's a bit more
cognitive sort of fely cognition if that
makes sense I don't know if that if that
if that's correct but I is it like
you've got like a perception action part
to those two in a way one's a bit more
perception heavy one's a bit more action
heavy
or let's return to that in a second
blue so I just wanted to comment while
we're here about like what you had said
in the um in the introduction video um
related to like why are we always trying
to you know estimate the states when
really we should be trying to estimate
the best policy right like that's what
we should be predicting over not trying
to predict the states like with the
bring three jackets instead of one
jacket and then you'll always be at the
right temperature like if if we prepare
versus trying to predict the the state
of of what's going to be I think that
that's a just was a neat thought that
occurred to me exactly um when there's
too much emphasis on precise estimates
of world States it's implicitly like
we're focusing so much on precise
estimates of world states that we'll
just know what to do when we have that
precise estimate it's like that's not
true it turns out that maybe again a on
digigit of precision or even uh to the
nearest 10 of the temperature from a
policy perspective you'll be fine if
it's um 20 Celsius plus or minus 10 you
might be fine within a broad range of
world State predictions from an action
selection policy because your action
selection could be cool I'll throw a
jacket in my backpack and then I'll be
fine whatever it is and so that is this
um two-stroke engine this handoff or
handshake between co- estimating states
and their transitions like weather in
the world and the transitions between
different weather states in the world
given what you know about weather we're
not on Mars it's not going to do a you
know acid rainstorm at 400 degrees so
it's like given what we know about the
distributions of the niche the
statistical regularities of the niche we
want to be co- estimating States and our
action action and perception and we want
to be doing that in a way that suffices
that's adequate to remain within our
preferred areas our preferred strange
detractors where we're able to basically
have reduced uncertainty about the
things that we care about the
physiological variables that matter like
our temperature and okay so it's it's it
is very cool and again just for those
who haven't seen these kinds of
equations that much the vertical line
means conditions on and then whatever
follows it you can think of is like
fixed so it's like you have a
spreadsheet and let's just say that the
rows are policies and the columns are
like State Transitions and so when you
fix on one it's like you pick out you
fix a column and then you're asking
about the distribution of that Vector
fixed on that column and similarly you
could fix a row select one row condition
on one row and then ask about the
distribution in that um line going
across and so that's the full Matrix and
uh also so that's related to what's
called marginal likelihood in basian
statistics the margin is literally the
margin of the page when they used to do
it with physical pages so it's like rows
by columns and the marginal likelihood
is related to the margin of the page
which is just so fun it's kind of like a
floppy disc icon but for
statistics um here's another cool piece
of the sophisticated inference paper and
I think there's a lot I'd like to learn
and ask here to Casper and others but
this formulation of policy P Pi
selection can people people can see my
red thing right Pi is related to the
argument minimization of free energy of
policy so this is saying the policy that
gets selected Pi is going to be like a
free energy minimization of G as a
function of all the policies that could
be done so of my affordances we're going
to do a free energy minimization and
that's how I'm going to select my policy
okay well what is g of Pi G of Pi is
related to the expectation of what risk
minus ambiguity so high risk is going to
be a higher number and that's worse in
this case we want it's like golf we want
to minimize the free energy and so we're
jointly trading off and there's some
natural logs and some negative natural
logs so it's sometimes a little bit hard
to see if you're going like up or
downhill which is why it's so important
to have it phrased like this but
basically risk is bad and ambiguity is
bad but it turns out with the natural
logs that you can just think of them as
being combined so it's like if we seek
to maximize um our Precision minimize
risk minimize ambiguity what we'll be
doing is actually a strict bound on the
intrinsic value and the extrinsic value
so this formulation of search of
Information Gain related to risk and
ambiguity turns out to be strictly
bounded by this value driven process so
worldview related to reward you see that
agents are reward Seekers and
uncertainty is something that they just
simply deal with or they figure out or
they Thrive despite in the active
inference perspective agents are
uncertainty reducers who obtain rewards
and if they don't they die that's
evolution
and so we're putting risk and
uncertainty first and so instead of
saying like well the agent predicts
value and that ends up reducing its
uncertainty about the world we're
actually saying no it's a way more
tractable calculation for the agent to
be reducing its uncertainty about action
again not just about states of the world
but the agent is reducing its
uncertainty about action through action
it's performing optimal foraging
experimentation to in order to reduce
its uncertainty about best actions and
it turns out that that is going to have
a bound it's always going to be
converging towards this perfect tradeoff
between intrinsic and extrinsic value
and special cases fall out of this where
certain variables are basically uh fixed
to zero so if you have no prior at the
beginning and you just um let it start
uh kind of draw from your first
observations you take those and you use
that as your first hyper prior that's
like the parametric empirical Baye and
in this case you end up recapitulating
several things from basian statistics
like Optimal basing design or just
surprise and then similarly if you set
the ambiguity to zero so like the case
in active inference 8 where the states
were perfectly observable like the
pendulum and the mountain car it wasn't
like it was getting a noisy estimate of
where it was on the mountain it knew
exactly where it was on the mountain and
in the case of of no ambiguity about
States again ambiguity is the the P
distribution of observations given
States so that's like given that it's
daytime am I seeing photons so if you
have no ambiguity about that then this
term is zero right which makes risk
minimization the imperative and that's
why when you get no ambiguity you find
that this whole framework collapses into
risk control whereas if you had risk
collapse to zero like it's a no risk
situation the only imperative would be
reduction of ambiguity so now let's
think about that in reward land if you
didn't have to seek value it could be
purely novelty based search whereas if
the only imperative were to obtain
short-term value you would not expect
that kind of agent to be engaged in a
creative search so it's sort of like
each of these are um phrasings whether
risk minus ambiguity or intrinsic minus
extrinsic value you can see how either
one of them could be like zeroed out and
what that would do for the other side or
you could imagine in realistic
situations where they're sort of like
tied up in a specific way so again you
could imagine a no risk scenario a no
ambiguity scenario no intrinsic or no
extrinsic any of these combinations
we'll do Stephen and then
Sasha yeah this is really good the way
you're putting this together here and
explaining it I think also this the
obviously these things um sometimes they
become really clear when it's an extreme
case and then you've got this blending
that's going on um you know it's not
fully any one of these but I I think
that no ambiguity piece is is is is a
useful one to think about what happens
sometimes when um well you could say I
don't know if you'd say Trump but the
when when in the politics when something
is if people say these people are bad
and you know you often see that even at
work and it's a no-brainer things are
said to be a no-brainer then suddenly
everyone the the the intrinsic value of
trying to explore other options is can
be collapsed in people and they just go
with the extrinsic value of gain because
there's no there's supposedly no
ambiguity and I think that that could be
interesting social y yep like we know
exactly how dangerous this virus is
there's no discussion about what the
risk minimizing policy is oh wait a
minute is there
Sasha okay very leading questions
um in hearing this description um just
really thinking
about using this to Define
play um and really seeing play as the
combination of factors that has um very
low
risk but like high uh value of
exploration and so setting up um things
that have low risk but High
opportunities for curiosity that would
be I guess for me fit into the category
of play so that's that's a good way to
think about it
and and another fun part there is like
when value is the imperative it's
difficult to be exploratory and creative
it's like maso's hierarchy of needs but
then when there can be the space where
you can actually engage in a novelty or
a curiosity guided search kind of the
prerequisite the enabling feature of
that is sufficiency at a material Level
so that isn't simply related to reward
we don't just give people reward kind of
dial up their dopamine and then they'll
be acting creatively it's actually like
we need to scaffold the agent in the
environment in a way where it can reduce
its risk so that it can tolerate higher
ambiguity or reduce ambiguity so that we
can engage with higher risk
scenarios so sometimes these
combinations of features even though
risk and ambiguity they're just English
words so really it is a about the
formalism but it helps us reimagine and
repartition and fluidly move across
partitionings for how to think about
these Nuance control problems
Sasha um also it makes me think about
how this is calmly studied like in
Psychology uh lab spaces
and yeah really thinking about like how
using this framework to figure out what
would make the
participants what's state that would put
them in um as well as how uh they feel
about the risk and ambiguity of the
situation that they're in because
depending on how you feel about
participating in research um that would
change what state of exploration or
curiosity um you might be in and that I
don't know it just really makes me
rethink a lot of
um research in this field because it's
ignoring or I I guess excluding one of
the key variables of this
process yep and it makes me think about
safe spaces but we could also say how
risky is this space that's sort of
related to safety those are like one
over each other you know risk equals one
over safety but also how ambiguous is
this space we want this space to be safe
so not risky but we also want this space
to be not ambiguous we want to be clear
and communicating about what this space
is however we don't want to make it so
unambiguous there's no room to play so
we want to have the optimal level of
ambiguity in Risk that's controlled
novelty that's parto optimality that's
free energy minimization that's living
on the frontier between performance and
Innovation so that's where all these
models can take us and that's why it
reimagines the bottom up versus top down
the explore versus exploit the
maximization in the long term versus the
short term those are all coming from the
reward mentality and when we think about
the situated agent reducing uncertainty
about action through action we have a
whole new set of ways to talk about
these questions Steph and then
blue and bring it back as well with this
paper and you know the way it talks
about Temple depth and and is it it can
also combined with this give a way to
think about what they call stages of
Readiness because people sort of think
oh you know could read this and like
okay we' made it safe I've said it's
safe I've told everyone it's safe
well it might be you've told them it's
safe and you've demonstrated it's safe
and the environment's been safe but it
might be five minutes it might be three
weeks of training before people start
to bring that safety into the way that
they balance these different parameters
you know so the way that there and it
could be that it crashes quite rapidly
positive or
negatively um as we saw earlier with the
the way that the uh the Dynamics work
and that that's quite um that shows that
the importance of facilitation and the
importance of the way the space is set
up the safety between participants and
all that sort of stuff cool
blue so I know that you said like we're
not going to unpack the formalism of the
intrinsic value and the extrinsic value
or at least you said that on the intro
video but um those two things like it
makes me think the special cases really
like you know they talked about no
intrinsic value but what about like no
extrinsic value like it just always
reminds me of like what about just
exploring for you know info gain or um
you know just out of curiosity to
satisfy that like for intrinsic value I
did note that I was like waiting for I
was like okay no risk no ambiguity um
then no intrinsic it's like the next one
and uh I wondered if that actually was
related to maximum entropy so it's like
given a distribution if you have no
preferences for value
then you're just sampling your
preference is to sample the distribution
unadulterated and so that is like Max
infog game Max ENT sampling neutrally
without preference across a distribution
and so that's very related to
statistical sampling techniques because
those computer algorithms have been
designed actually without a preference
Vector in mind just to sample
distributions like Monte Carlo Markov
chain methods and so now we're taking a
sampling agent you're sampling
temperatures but you don't want just all
temperatures for that distribution you
want to sample repeatedly from body
temperature however there might be
another distribution where you do want
to have a very very exploratory sampling
pattern let's just see if there's any
other interesting stuff so here is from
sophisticated inference uh another kind
of roll out and here we can see
observations and then there's different
actions that can be taken and each of
those actions would lead to different
observations and so on and so it gets
exponentially large and this is just
like early chess algorithms they used to
do if this then that if this then that
and they would do these roll outs and
then they'd prune this Branch oh that
doesn't look that good so I'm not going
to explore that way and since those sort
of tree pruning chess algorithms there's
been many developments in chess and
other algorithms for this kind of
decision-making and so here's the
structure of the model and here's that
roll out and then one big question is
how can we look down the branches that
are most informative not just fantasize
and dream about the one in a billion
branches that's the best not negatively
ruminate and get dwelling on the one
branch that's the worst but how can we
sample information across this branching
tree pattern in a way that leads to
effective action in the world and then
here's another integrative plot that
they made which is showing that
basically uh there's a few ways to think
about active inference what it's doing
here it's minim minimizing risk and
minimizing ambiguity okay so that's
related to the this phrasing on the top
minimize risk minimize ambiguity okay
make it safe make it clear positive way
of saying it the negative way is
minimize risk minimize ambiguity so
policies States observations states are
the hidden part of the world
observations you know photons on my
retina policies where my eyes move and
so the risk framing is you should be
minimizing free energy in a way that red
reduces risk and ambiguity about this
chain that connects policy states and
outcomes another branch of active
inference is actually sort of like a yin
and yang this is like a push pull it's
saying minimize the entropy of the
distribution of outcomes so achieve
predictable outcomes reduce big
reduction on there and expand here with
the information gain and so instead of
hey do something that's like creative
but FYI don't be risky and don't be
ambiguous here is like be as clear as
you can and predictable as you can the
outcomes while being as infog gain and
creative as you possibly can and so I
like this because it's sort of like
instead of two things that you want to
run away from and then hopefully you
become creative in the Gap this is like
something to run away from and something
to run towards so it rephrases that risk
and ambiguity minimization as actually a
push pull of a minimization of surprise
about
observations and a maximization of the
Information Gain given the um policies
that can be carried out so I kind of
like that graphic and then um just in
the last couple minutes um Casper and
several other authors will be on in
early April hopefully before then as
well for active 19 and that will be
pretty cool but here's where they walk
step by step M1 at each time step the
agent is inferring how hidden states are
related to outcomes then we see that sa
AO mapping and now we have this and D is
the initial States now we're going to
take this single time Point model and
use B to ask how States change through
time then we're going to take M2 that
States changing through time and put it
within a bigger model of M3 which is
action so policy is influencing how
States change their time the B Matrix
policy is being selected by what
minimization of free energy G how do we
calculate minimized free energy
including a preference Vector C and then
we have a prior over policies this is
related to the affordances so now we're
not just doing State prediction at a
moment but through time M1 and M2 and
we're going to be doing policy selection
on that right now and then where we got
to in sophisticated affective inference
was this M4 layer which is State
observation mappings through time or at
a given moment and Through Time with the
A and the B and choosing policy using
our C preference vector
and G the minimizing of free energy and
about that free energy we're going to
have a Precision we're going to have a
prior on our Precision this is our
metacognition and here's where veilance
enters the picture which is anxiety bad
anxiety comes from high uncertainty so
if you have high Precision on free
energy you're going to feel better if
you have low uncertainty or low
certainty about free energy it's going
to lead to anxiety not because the
expected value of the outcomes is
negative so not within that reward first
mindset but in the Precision first
mindset even a positive expected value
where the high variance can be anxiety
producing so we kind of uh return to the
paper as being the summation of these
two citations building before just like
so many other papers are building on
citations it's always just like tips of
icebergs all the way down Markov
citation blankets all the way down and
we can ask our kind of usual sets
questions and people can provide their
closing thoughts or questions or what
would they like addressed in 11.2 next
week just what's something fun that
anyone or each of you thought about
today and then also to kind of maybe
even close on a note about how we can
have accessible formalisms for active
inference and include people in the
discussion who speak math or not who
speak English or not so how do we
communicate it make make it exciting
build those bridges to other areas any
closing thoughts on
that
Stephen lots of really good stuff I mean
I suppose there's there's some elements
of this where I'd love to find a way I'm
trying to find a way to take people into
an activity where you know well I
suppose some of us do that you know with
play or with an exploration different
types of exploration activities that
maybe illustrate some of these and then
they get unpacked after um because it
maybe just some of this stuff is in its
nature pretty involved but that's still
good um so I like the way you've been
describing it but maybe there's um yeah
maybe there's something then that this
now Bridges with something else that's
experiential cool anyone else have a
thought on that
yeah I think that the questions I would
like to have the authors or anyone
familiar with the formalism help us on
would be how how can we um communicate
and understand the differences between
partitioning risk and ambiguity this way
or that way how do we know what to apply
in What scenario how does it change how
we act how does it change how we model
systems how would we infer it in a
system how do we disconnect the qualia
the experience of surprise uncertainty
ambiguity risk veilance how do we
disconnect from the qualia so that we
can apply it to systems that are um on
the other side of our marov blanket
systems that are we are not experiencing
but are acting in a way uh in an
intentional stance way they're acting as
if they had these kinds of attributes
well um if there's any other thoughts we
can definitely hear it but otherwise
very excellent discussion wait Stephen
do you have another point
oh so everyone thanks for the awesome
discussion there's a uh feedback form in
the calendar invite if you'd like to
take a look and fill that out otherwise
people who are watching it live and in
replay thanks so much means a lot to us
and we hope to hear your questions hear
your thoughts so that we can address
them in 11.2 and thanks so much for a
great 2020 we are almost there this is
the pen ultimate active Stream So
everyone thanks so much and we'll talk
later